[Musica]
io cesca buona questa qua è una tecnica
mica male allora andiamo e da un po che
non faccio l'imposta ragazzi speriamo di
giocarcela bene le ultime parole famose
però se mickey segni chi passa di qua
deve stare molto attento a miti morto
subito
timore sempre subito poverino ha provato
andare su prova ad andare solo vedere se
riesco ad aggirare gli altri con il
problema perché se no di chi non lo fate
giocare ho trovato il cadavere di miti
giù in communication dice ancora non ho
capito chi era con potrebbe essere eco
io sono stato in pietra io ho fatto sto
steroli sono stato talmente io perché
noi aprono conti li ha fatti terriero
spesso sono i tre si mette anche me
stesso io mi aspetterei se non fossi io
però non ho niente però ed ecco che noia
e io almeno più di sete tranquillo
è vero soprattutto dagli altri mamma mia
che difesa raga ottima allora sapori ci
vediamo a fare un sabotaggio mentre sto
qua sto vicino andando siamo sicuri non
ammazza cia vicenda era quell alibi che
noia che sta guardando da due ore dalle
camere st maledetta c'è leo che mi segue
e leo e io e leo facciamo che me lo
tengo proprio come alibi non faccio
assolutamente niente
io l ho me lo tengo completamente come
alibi leo deve essere la persona che
dirà fa vj è stato come tutto il tempo e
non ha fatto niente lui deve dire questo
quindi devo proprio stare attento perché
siamo veramente troppo attaccati
ok brava cesca che è stata lei a ok beh
insomma che noia può essere montato ad
essere sospettati rai possono reggere
sono io e leo siamo stati vicini ma
allora si corregge l'ho segnalata io è
un contratto solo se ska che non so se
volevo uccidermi ma aveva il col dow
però non stava andando dalla navigation
alla caffetteria
però io posso confermare che fa perché
lorenzo e le ore erano sempre insieme
però mi sembrava strano perché sembrava
che cercassero uno di due cerca di
seguire l'altro no io l'ho seguito il
carretto st botta al mese sto attaccato
nonne o leo milioni stava appiccica è
infatti l'ho visto nel telecamere che si
vedeva proprio che era palese che noi
stessi se posso io c'erano albi però sto
rotonda con lamberto è lecito ed ossa e
quindi mancati punto manca al menisco e
quindi fate come volete proprio ai non
ne ho fatta ma uno che è stata carente 2
ma io l'ho proviente finita manca uno
non ti regalo finite tutte però
dalla schipa io sto scappando vuota
perché non mischiare ho detto che un
sospetto non ti sei tu l usb stick
emettere 21 cesca vieni qua e vabbè ma
cercano mi dà una mano cerca non mi va
di nomi da veramente mano perché dovrei
doveva stare vicino a me cesca mannaia o
se cerca fosse stata vicino a me avremmo
aspettato il cooldown per far fuori
tutti e due perché se ci poteva stare
sta roba ragazzone reattore
allora cosa è successo e se chiusa la
porta di nola ma di fatto e questo io
evento del camera a guardare fisso
charlie salire per entrare nella stanza
mi giro veloce a rientrare e stecca
scomparsa di fianco a me e non l'ho
visto uscì dalla stanza via di chiusura
che ha mentre io stavo cercando di
vedere chi meno hughes la prima del
relatore sopra l'unione dottore che tu
jobs entrata nella stanza azionando
contro telecamera che era gara è da tech
vi avevo detto filmato di tener conto di
tutti e tre charlie è morta e tirano
accusato talmente tanto speciale
non votate fermi chi avete votato
anch'io che è vissuta come nei racconti
di fenoglio premette emergency e votate
da tecno via ci sono assolutamente vero
questa è almeno così
cosa avete fatto minchia veramente
maturati scritto come in parte sta
morendo fiera ragazzi occhi vi ha
schiacciato il meeting all'ospedale
mutati e sta lì fermo abbiamo vinto
ragazzi forse perché se lo fa dove de
paris con te lo assicuro
siamo 2 contro 2 dopo ospedale per
ragazzi il fatto o five giuste
non so che fine abbia fatto perché io ho
visto intralciarla due nuovi soci peste
ma zero e secondo me troppe volte ma ora
mi sento mi prendo la colpa mi pare che
ha perso rai da un applauso
sei sicuro o perso se avevo sicuro
incredibili banca un sistema che al
lupus in fabula giorno potrete smetterla
di giocare sia incredibile ragazzi bene
ragazzi il momento sta partita me la
voglio giocare proprio totalmente safe
speriamo che non mi passi qualcuno
vicino stai fini sta veramente seguendo
mi dà fastidio è finita troppo seguendo
step vista troppo seguendo via via via
via via è la madonna
fermi tutti sono r che noia da stava non
è che noia mi stava seguendo step e mi
sono mentre andavo verso quel corridoio
trovato ad una mano non è stefano nesta
effe che io ero con lui attaccato
proverò mi stava parlando dove appunto
quindi non può essere che se non nessuno
andato sotto il lato al volo la dia e la
riportato ma non penso di si può fare
si può fare ma no era proprio vicino a
me no ok perché io tanto vicino a se
stessa tanto vicino allori e quindi
eravamo i tre linea troviamo step to mi
confermi confermi di nichi pesi era
dietro allora non è niki però il corpo
era molto vicino c'è a era verso
caffetteria quindi è arrivato la
caffetteria chi l'ha uccisa ok sicuro
non è arrivato io stavo in ossigeno da
sono sparato in ossigeno fa la task e
sono rimasto li ha vinti l'avete
riportare fabregas più più ampio
io no io ho fatto una tasca dei ricavi
solo chiesa però non sono in viso dire
che è stato fatto non mi ricordano
ricorda i nomi delle stanze
ma sono quasi convinto sia cesca pietro
mi sa di buono di no rimango con nichi
vediamo
dobbiamo stare vicini ragazzi perché si
assottiglia e 49 cerca ragazza e cesca
maledetta che mi segue e cesca e cesca
so che cesca
sono convinto che sia cesca
da come si muove proprio la conosco la
conosco e cesca e c'è sky mi vuole fare
fuori
guarda che mi segue da due ore charlie
nome la conta giusta prosegue lei admin
o no ma ragazzi mica loro addosso stare
conservare perché sicuramente qualcuno
mi ammazza mentre osservo hockey cesca
step attenzione cerca seguiva stef
charlie è passato arrivava guarda che
casino mi sto pagando prodotto ragazzi
visto veramente che abbiamo tutto le
tasse non le stiamo facendo le tasche
non le stiamo facendo
secondo me cesca ragazzi di cesca nel
body l'inchino che stanno c'è un body
non solo pratichiamo la stanza da destra
il mezzo a sinistra basso a sinistra
bello warren join.me accorso incontro
cesca machiste volta cesca non è perché
era fianco si chiama guardarli
io ho scappato anche charlie non mi ha
ucciso nei ovviamente avete scappato
tutti va bene
era da un po che volevo farlo che poi
morire il brivido vale ragazzi secondo
me io rimango sul fatto che sia cesca
poi magari mi sbaglio però secondo me
eccetera dopo sapete cosa faccio provato
accusarla come l'accusano di solito
avendo se si piglia male se si pia male
allora non e cesca se noi cercano nenni
chi poteva usciamo non è di chi poteva
veramente uccidermi stepper a step l'ho
visto l'ho visto l'ho visto ho visto la
stessa se fra sta trasferendo era step
era step
no so quale ieri non sapevo fare le
porte niente abbiamo di salire in piedi
più di me stessa la regina del maghetto
ha preferito
beh nessuno ha sospettato di malpensa
volta comunque vero ma 15 addirittura
prima la prima assoluta per uccidere il
proprio miccoli cap
[Musica]